what do you think about the choice of
Peter Capaldi and the leads I think it's
brilliant I've always really loved him I
really admire Jim he's a brilliant actor
he's both absolutely terrifying and
incredible with comedy proper firm
brilliant actor he is going to be
stunning every single doctor has been
brilliant as far as I can see he is
spectacularly clever casting I think
he's an utterly wonderful actor and I
have no doubt the beauty of all day who
was an axe factor I've been watching for
many years and admiring he's going to be
pretty brilliant
I'm thanks i ed he's gonna be brilliant
I love him he looks a bit like William
Hart know he's got the traits and it's
just like he was fantastic in the car
the fun paid he's just got all the
qualities you need I can't wait I think
he's gonna be fantastic he's just such a
good actor he's just gonna give it up
all new can a doctor I think it being
the kind of old fashioned scary gravitas
my favorite William Hart the chemistry
between him and Clara is going to be
amazing
I really like the fact that he's a bit
older you know I think would be it will
open up a whole new set of of fans I
think he's gonna bring that dark
mysterious the poplar dark mysterious he
looks like he can get really moody as
well he'll bring back some of the
traditional Doctor Who magic than like
many years ago he's a thousand year old
Time Lord from a stuffy society let's
see what he can do let's see how he can
really be from a grumpy
to view and I can't wait more of the
granddad type rolled the saw early stuff
I think more and less of the Companions
falling in love with it one of the most
popular artists of course is as iconic
as Tom Baker the most people regarded as
sort of that was as good as it got I
missed that kind of Nutty Professor
dragging his student along atmosphere
that doctor who hadn't had in quite a
while
and I think Peter Capaldi's got the
potential to to to create a fully
rounded character with spiky and
dysfunctional but interesting
charismatic is a character actor and
that's very much the requirement for
Doctor Who these many faceted you know
is this fugitive almost adolescent
sometimes but there's you know you look
at William Hartnell and jumper two is
the same he'd he had that proper
gravitas it makes absolute sense it's a
really wise choice
he is an absolute gentleman and
incredibly funny and incredibly talented
and I I genuinely mean he when I say he
couldn't have to a nicer guy the fact
that moth had said that they had him in
four years ago and they were considering
him so it shows you that he's the right
man for the job
really he's almost like a classic doctor
he just perfect
hopefully you've swear like it's true
for like welcome so I think we're all
secretly hoping that he will I'm looking
forward to see how he destroy all the a
now it's time for the old beast to smile
that you were better at said I think
it's a wonderful decision and I think
you'll be absolutely I'll start watching
our really interesting